foreign
we're back let's go out to Omaha
Nebraska what's up Jane how we doing
hi John I'm good how are you partying
what's up that's not true I'm not
partying at all what's up
it's a long thing but more so about how
to move on or forgive after and I don't
even know if this is the right term like
emotional infidelity okay talk to me
about it
so my husband and I have been together
for over seven years now just married
for a little bit less than two
and last December I found that he was
having like inappropriate conversations
with like not only a co-worker but an
employee of his
um so inappropriately yeah like sexual
sexualized okay all right yep yep
um
it never even crossed my mind but you
know looking of course hindsight looking
back that November we traveled out of
town with the what this woman and her
husband
for a conference so we were all down in
Florida and they wanted to have rooms
close to each other so that we could
hang out and everything blah blah blah
well yeah I gotta just say that's the
most spurned woman thing blah blah blah
right yeah so good like it was just it
was odd like okay whatever that's fine
wow in December all right my husband
um was taking our kids to go play
dodgeball for a work event
um I was supposed to go to a concert
that same Saturday night with a group of
girlfriends we both had plans great it
was fine well I ended up getting sick
that Friday night before
um so I was out with the flu while
undergoing IVF treatments so that I'm
sure didn't help everything as well
um took our kids to play dodgeball hey
you need anything before I leave nope
just get out of here I don't feel well
don't want the kids around
so that'll be perfect
um his plan was to go to dodgeball and
then everybody because everybody brought
their kids to they were all going to
meet up at a restaurant for dinner
afterwards and just hang out after and
have a couple drinks not a big deal
so he kind of fell off the face of the
Earth that afternoon slash evening
um come to find out my mother-in-law
actually came to pick up my kids just a
couple hours later
and took them to see Santa and my
husband
decided to go to his buddy's
girlfriend's house with him and his
buddy who was a newly divorced gentleman
and this other girl
by themselves
and this had been set up like two weeks
in advance
what happened they had a yeah so they
had a whole group conversation for a
week before
and he just gave me a bunch of false
details there was never what happened at
that house
well I don't know
he turned his location off on his phone
what does he say happen at that house
while I like to think that nothing
physically happened no what did he say
what did he say oh
beers and eight piece unplayed cards
that's the dumbest thing I ever heard
like and with his buddy they do do that
but it's always guys and then we go out
to our cabin and we do that like his
friend like I've known this guy for
years as well so
I just thought well that's just weird
why would you turn your location off you
were not honest with me about going to
This Woman's house and then I found out
of course through
questioning I just had a great gut
instinct unfortunately like nope they
didn't go to dinner they went to This
Woman's home he actually left their home
with this other girl to drive her back
to work because she was actually
supposed to be at work training a new
person
so they drove around
and were hanging out by themselves for
an undetermined period of time all right
let's so let's stop playing Matlock
bring me to the bring me to the present
like this clearly this happened right
yes and
um there's a I've just just lost it um
it's too early in the morning
um there's a legal term which basically
says
there's a moment when
um the judge turns to the jury and
basically because of the deception that
appears to be happening in the room you
all get to make up whatever you want
maybe it's pleading the fifth I my
lawyer friends are going to be
embarrassed that I don't know the sculpt
off my head but they're basically
because you created this environment
Jerry y'all get to imagine whatever
worst case scenario you want to and that
is fact because this person won't speak
up and let us know what actually
happened and so I'm giving you that
opportunity
because your husband chose to deceive
and lie you and lie in so many ways in
such a premeditated way you get to
imagine whatever you want happen to that
house
yeah okay so bring me um we are months
away from December so bring me to up to
speed how can I help
um
the entire conversation that we had
about that and he kept trying to cover
it up and then he lied more and yeah
he's a liar and he cheats on you
continued to communicate
okay he's opting out of relationship
with you
he's out he has opted out
so is Jack
is just conversations there's none
whatever you're about to tell me there's
none here's why because his wife looked
at him and said I think he cheated on me
with this woman he said I promise I
didn't she's just my friend and you as
his wife said this makes me
uncomfortable this makes me sick to my
stomach I don't trust this and any
self-respecting romantic partner in that
moment goes then this ends because there
is no other relationship more important
than this
okay
so whatever justification there is I
don't care even despite how
um not cool it is it's probably the most
benign way I could say that besides
possibly illegal possibly whatever
if it's somebody that works for you then
for sure sure I'm gonna have somebody
like this person's boss this person's
leader talk to them not me ask me where
that communication is a problem well so
he's her boss
um
so this was it last Monday
was when I found that she had texted him
and what's even better is that her best
friend texted him an inappropriate
picture of these two girls
and he you know deleted it from his
phone and he ended up responding like
I'm married this is inappropriate I'm
blocking your number don't ever try and
contact me again good for him
but
like the fact that that happened like
obviously like he has he does not do
well with confrontation where I'm all
for it if it the situation calls for it
except you're not dealing you're not
dealing with this why not no so this I
did so I actually told him that if you
don't go to HR and address it I will and
I promise that you will both lose your
jobs I do not care okay this is not okay
I'm at that point where
I'm already like one foot out the door
okay so what's your question
well okay so this girl
this girl removed from her person you
keep going back to the story tell me you
asked me your question ask me a question
I'm just trying to decide like
do I just call it quit
s them as now you know he says it's not
going to continue
what's not going to continue
didn't he say that last time
that's the thing however all of the
conversations that I had seen were work
related because given his position he
has to be available like 24 7.
um
like he's a director of an emergency
room so he has to be available at all
times and as the fact that she was his
employee there were times that she had
to be in communication with him yeah I
get that I mean I mean I get it in
theory right I've been on call 24 7 365.
I get that life and you have to you just
gotta answer I get that and you know he
kept the conversations very short and
sweet he actually did have a documented
conversation with her between this last
incident and the first incident where it
was documented with another member of
the staff and HR that your communication
with me is not appropriate that's not
what you should be doing you need to
keep it professional Okay the reason
that you should be acting this way so
there was a previously documented
so that that that that to me like
um is a step in the right direction
but right you keep focusing on him and
you're in so doing you're avoiding Jane
you're avoiding you okay
the only way I've seen this and by the
way I have seen this repaired
completely
like and not only repaired but something
else more magnificent has been built in
its place okay not to say that people
should run out and cheat on their spouse
just so they can build something new no
but um I've seen it happen
two things have to be present for that
to happen or three the first one is
everybody's got to be honest about what
happened
everybody
and you still have doubts to the
original Integrity of his story
and just as a guy Roman walking down the
road who's been married for a long long
time that story sounds sketch here's why
um
if you premeditate something for weeks
to set something up and you go to the
trouble to deceive your wife have
somebody else come pick up your kids I
mean the whole the whole thing
you don't do that for a couple of beers
and cards
you know what I mean you can play you
could play you go drink beers and and
play cards at worst you tell your wife
hey I'm going over to my buddy's house
and you don't tell him that she's going
to be there
you don't go through this whole thing
something else was going on okay so
that's number one I don't buy the story
you gotta have complete honesty across
the board
and that might be you saying okay this
is the moment
this is the moment
I'm interested in staying in this thing
because I I have a sense in your heart
you are but you feel like you should
leave and
that you're kind of stuck between a rock
and a hard place in that Rock and Hard
Place is Jane left and Jane right so I
think there's something to be said for
I'm interested in it but we can go no
further until you say everything
the second one is you have to be honest
and very very clear
about what trust rebuilding looks like
because you can't have him read your
mind
yeah you have to say if there is any
work conversation between you and this
woman I get to see it and by the way we
review your text once a week or I'm
going to put this app on your phone if
that's what you need
if you turn your tracker off
then I file for divorce like whatever
you think you need for a season
to begin to rebuild Trust
but most people don't have the courage
to say what they actually need and then
they just get mad when the other person
doesn't meet some doesn't read their
mind right the third thing is if you are
in
he and again he's not on the phone I'd
be having a whole different conversation
if he was on the phone but with you if
you choose to stay
you have chosen to stay
and this cannot be something that you
keep in your back pocket every day for
the rest of your marriage
and that's what I think I'm definitely
struggling with I can tell because even
even the ability just to say hey what's
going on in your heart I got it I want I
gotta tell the story again I gotta tell
the story again I gotta tell the story
again and my Pro I guarantee you you
have looped that story in your mind for
months right
yeah
and have you imagined things that
happened in your mind for months oh yeah
yeah yes
and then you get sick and then you get
mad at him and so now you've Crea he's
granted he set this world up but he is
now
um on the receiving end of your
imagination
and as I told you earlier he created
that right by by just giving you a
stupid story you didn't even try hard to
lie to you right uh by giving you a
stupid story fine I get to make up
whatever I want them
and so those three things have to be
true for this thing to work and what
does that look like in real time
um the first one is you have to decide
that every time that thought Pops in
your mind about him walking in that
apartment
that you stop that right there
you don't go that extra Road where she
walks up to him and he reaches up and
undoes the top but you can't you can't
do that you have to choose to opt out of
that imaginary scenario because you
don't know
and even if you do know you have to
choose to not continue to revisit that
scenario because you are building
something new now
that's your work
but also I'll say it again you can't do
that work on a on a foundation of
dishonesty
and he's got to come clean
yeah
and if he comes clean and says I'm
looking in the eyes I'm holding both
your hands I'm sitting here with our
counselor
I did not have a physical relationship
with her
I sounded like Bill Clinton just then
um yeah
Kelly just look I sound like Bill
Clinton just said
um you have to decide whether I can
believe him or not
mm-hmm
and I've heard men look me in the eye
and say dude I didn't do anything
and she don't believe me I've heard that
and I've also heard women be like no I
trust him and I'm like what why are you
trying so I can't give that to you but
you're gonna have to decide that that's
gonna be have to be a call that you make
I recommend having a neutral third party
there whether that's a counselor whether
that's a minister y'all trust or that
somebody that is going to help navigate
the conversation
um
but it's got to start from a place of
honesty it's got to start from a place
of you telling the truth like here's
what I need
and it's going to be you on your side
saying I'm gonna stop going back to
I'm gonna try to build something new and
he's gonna have to live into the things
that you requested of him he's going to
be a person of integrity and stop
um either stuck in sexually explicitly
with is someone who works for him which
is completely inappropriate or sleeping
with somebody that works for him it's
completely inappropriate whatever he's
got to stop all that nonsense and it
sounds like what you're saying is he's
making some steps in that right
direction
I also know
it is so easy that when somebody has a
crush on you that you lean into that
feels good feels awesome
and
it just becomes a slippery slow right
she becomes a slippers up I get it
but y'all gonna have to choose to build
something new regardless
let me know that conversation goes Jane
I wish I could just wave my magic wand
and say this is what you should do but
there's a lot of complexity here
um and I still don't think the truth is
out
and if he wants to call me I'd love to
talk to him
that would make for
um some clarity for me and probably be
offer some clarity for the audience too